Good evening. We're going to discuss a very
contemporary halachic shaila that is contemporary because it
applies nowadays, but it only applied now, it
only has been a shaila for a number
of years. The shaila is an ancient shaila,
but the application is exceptional and has to
do possibly or maybe possibly not with the
fact that we are zocha to have Baruch
Hashem Eretz Yisrael with shlita on Eretz Yisrael.
We'll see how that might bear a nafka
mina to the fact that there is a
government that might be in control of Eretz
Yisrael. We'll see that's quoted where Rav Shlomo
Zalman will apply that svara, which we'll see
soon. So the question is, Eilat is known
for its beautiful coral reef. I've gone snorkeling
there. Menachem, you went snorkeling there? No, you
never went? Okay, I'll have to take my
son snorkeling there. It's a beautiful, beautiful place.
But you're not allowed to snorkel, you're not
allowed to swim on Yom Tov, so the
question is, if you go to Eilat for
Sukkot, for Pesach, for Shavuot, are you going
to be keeping one day of Yom Tov
or are you going to be keeping two
days of Yom Tov? nafka mina, could you
go snorkeling on second day Yom Tov? Is
there a second day Yom Tov, meaning what's
the shaila? The shaila is, is it Eretz
Yisrael, is it Chutz La'aretz? That's really our
question. It's a question only for those who
are bnei Chutz La'aretz. That is correct. For
those who are bnei America who are visiting
Eretz Yisrael and follow the minhag of Klal
Yisrael that has—the minhag that Klal Yisrael has
had for the past few thousand years, then
we would keep two days wherever we would
go. But yes, it's a question for Israelis
who very much do like to go to
Eilat. I actually drove Berel Wein home this
afternoon from YU, he spoke at YU. I
told him I was speaking about this tonight.
He said—he had a good line. He said
something about the reason why there's not such
a big shaila of going to—something, he had
some funny joke about the fact that there
are no yamim tovim in the winter. The
winter's when everybody likes to go, all the
Israelis go to Eilat in the winter, but
there's no Yom Tov in Eilat in the
winter, so it's not such a shaila. Okay,
so let's start, we'll begin—we have to begin
really with the discussion of what are taka
the gvulot of Eretz Yisrael. If it's included
in Eretz Yisrael, good; if it's not included
in Eretz Yisrael, then that probably is our
answer. It's Chutz La'aretz or Eretz Yisrael, one
of the other, right? We will see it
is not so simple, but what will be
simple is whether it's in Eretz Yisrael. Let's
look at some pesukim Bamidbar, Parshat Masei, Perek
Lamed Daled. Zot Ha'aretz, HaKadosh Baruch Hu says,
asher tipol lachem l'nachala. Why does the Torah
have to tell us where the aretz is?
Zogt Rashi, sheharbeh mitzvot nohagot ba'aretz v'einan nohagot
b'chutz la'aretz. So therefore the Torah has to
tell you which are the borders of Eretz
Yisrael so you know whether the mitzvot hatluyot
ba'aretz apply or don't apply. So let's get
into some of the borders in pasuk gimmel.
v'haya lachem p'at negev, the southern border, mimidbar
tzin al yedei edom, it's on the bottom,
the southeast corner. v'haya lachem gvul negev, this
will be your southern border, miketzeh yam hamelach
kedma, starting from the southern tip of yam
hamelach. That's going to be the bottom of
Eretz Yisrael according to the Torah. And then
it's going to head—that will be the eastern
border. That will be the eastern edge of
the southern border, correct. As Rashi
explains, ruach dromis min hamizrach, now we're going
to outline going from east from the—from the
bottom tip of the yam hamelach going towards—if
you're facing a map, going leftwards towards Egypt,
towards the Mediterranean. So what does the Torah
say? This is where the border goes: venasav
lachem hagvul minegev l'ma'aleh akrabim, that the border
will go just around ma'aleh akrabim. Now,
without knowing, without having a map in front
of us, I will tell you what the
potential possibilities of this pasuk is telling us.
I don't know if it's this pasuk or
another pasuk, there's a wadi that had become
famous, I believe, in 1967, Wadi el-Arish. Wadi
el-Arish is a natural geological phenomenon, meaning it's
been there for thousands of years. It's not
a new thing. That's one opinion,
there's Nachal Mitzrayim, which might be Wadi el-Arish.
If you have a picture of Eretz Yisrael,
sort of draw a line, a crooked line
just around from the bottom tip of yam
hamelach, of the Dead Sea, maybe a little
bit more south, and then draw a line
basically a little crooked that goes towards Egypt.
The line would be well, well, well above
Eilat. Eilat is well below. this border according
to just about all opinions, if not every
opinion. There is no opinion that assumes that
Eilat, that Eretz Yisrael does Baruch Hashem own
now, nobody holds that it was part of
what we'll call biblical or Eretz Yisrael that's
described in the Chumash. Did in the time
of Shlomo HaMelech, did Shlomo HaMelech or in
the time of David, did they, did Klal
Yisrael annex as far south as Eilat? There
are interesting Psukim in all kinds of places
as explained by different Rishonim and Meforshim that
may indicate some things yes, some things no,
but it's certainly not a clear point. There's
no definitive indication that Eilat should be in
the borders of Eretz Yisrael. So at this
point let's assume that Eilat is not in
the borders of any version of Eretz Yisrael
other than the modern state of Israel. So
therefore with that in mind we're going to
have to work with the famous Gemara that
teaches us the foundations of Yom Tov Sheini
shel Galuyos, which is source number 2. Of
course the Yom Tov Sheini shel Galuyos question,
whether Yom Tov should be one day or
two days, starts with the fact that in
the olden days in the time of the
Sanhedrin the Rosh Chodesh was determined by eidus
that would be testified in the Beis HaMikdash
and then messages would be sent out from
the Beis HaMikdash to the rest of Klal
Yisrael in Eretz Yisrael and then outside of
Eretz Yisrael as well and that would tell
them when they should make Yom Tov ten
days later for Yom Kippur, 15 days later
for Sukkos and Pesach, six days later for
Shavuos. Let's look at the Gemara inside because
the end of the Gemara will be very
important in our analysis. Yom Tov Sheini shel
Galuyos, where do they come from? Why is
there Yom Tov Sheini shel Galuyos? Detnan, there's
the Gemara in Beitzah daled amud bais, source
number 2. Barishona originally hayu masian masu'os, they
would lift up fires on the hilltops. My
son and I are familiar with the drive
through from Yerushalayim to Tveria on kvish 90.
90. Thank you, towards kvish 90. 90. We
pass the big mountaintops, the very high mountaintops
below Yericho where that mountaintop, what was it
called? Not Yotvata, Sartava. Sartava and
other such mountains that are mentioned in the
mishnayos in Rosh Hashanah. But we know where
some of these mountains, they're the tallest mountains
going that would lead you all the way
from Yerushalayim till Bavel. On the mountaintops they
would raise these, light the fires to indicate
that the Beis Din had decided that it
was a new month. Mishekilklu HaKusim, right the
Kusim played games with us and they started
lighting fires on mountaintops even when it was
not Rosh Chodesh. Hishkinu sheyislochim yotzin, they sent
out messengers with secret codes and based on
these messages when the messenger with the secret
code would arrive from Yerushalayim they'd know that
Yerushalayim was taka mekudash at whatever given day.
Says the Gemara, Ve'ilu batlu Kusim avdinan chad
yoma veHeicha de'matu shlochim avdinan chad yoma. Wherever
the shlochim would arrive they knew exactly when
Rosh Chodesh was, therefore they knew exactly when
Yom Tov was. If you know exactly when
Yom Tov is then you don't have to
keep a second day. You know when Yom
Tov is. Asks the Gemara, vehashtah deyad'inan bikvia
deyarcha, the third line vehashtah deyad'inan bikvia deyarcha,
we know when the kvius of the yerach
is, we know when the new months are
nowadays, we have a calendar. mai ta'ama avdinan
trei yomei? Why do we have to still
keep two days? I want to give you
a little bit of history that the Ritva
shared with us. If you look at page
2, the Ritva in Beitzah, I'm sorry the
Ritva in Rosh Hashanah yud ches amud aleph,
I have it on towards the bottom of
page 2 in the middle of source number
7 in the italics. The Ritva explains this
line of the Gemara in the italics. What
happened? Aval achshav, you see the Ritva's lashon
italics on the bottom of page 2, achshav
bazman hazeh anu yodei bikvia deyarcha. He's explained
the Gemara that we just mentioned and nowadays
we do know when Rosh Chodesh is, we
have a calendar. Why? sheharei amad Hillel HaZaken.
Who and when was Hillel HaZaken? Says the
Ritva, Hillel HaZaken was the Nasi acharon shehaya
beYisrael. He was the final Nasi in that
position of nesius of Klal Yisrael. He was
beno shel Rebbi Yehuda Nasi ben beno shel
Rabbeinu HaKadosh. So there's two Rebbi Yehuda HaNasi's.
There's Rebbi Yehuda HaNasi Rabbeinu HaKadosh who wrote
the mishnayos, his grandson was also Rebbi Yehuda
HaNasi and his that son meaning Rebbi Yehuda
HaNasi Rabbeinu HaKadosh great-grandson was Hillel HaZaken. Hillel
HaZaken, so that's three generations after the mishnayos
were written. So we're talking
350 of the Common Era. Around 350 of
the Common Era, give or take 20, 30
years, what happened then? kesherah hasmichus
mismatet, he realized that the people who are
have smicha in order to be on the
Beis Din to pasken the Rosh Chodesh you
have to have smicha. If you have a
Beis Din that doesn't, if you don't have
a Beis Din of smuchim of official people
with official smicha from Moshe Rabbenu, you can't
do Kiddush HaChodesh. Once he saw that that
institution of smicha was starting to weaken, there
weren't as many people who had smicha, probably
because of Roman persecution, v'shelo yiheyeh l'Yisrael Beis
Din and therefore if that happens Bnei Yisrael
won't have a Beis Din that could do
Kiddush HaChodesh anymore. So keep in mind, Bnei
Yisrael were mekadesh the Chodesh after Churban HaBayis
for another nearly 300 years, right? The Churban
HaBayis was in 70 of the Common Era,
we're talking now 350 of the Common Era,
so 280 years later they still were doing
Kiddush HaChodesh al pi re'iya after Churban HaBayis
for 280 years or so. So he realized,
but it's going to, you know, he realized
that it might not be able to continue
too much longer. What did he do? amad
v'iber kol hashanim he calculated all of the
future years, al pi cheshbon, v'kidesh kol hachodashim
v'kol hamoados. There at that time in the
year whatever 350 of the Common Era, he
sat down and figured out all the future
months and all the future Yom Tovim and
he was mekadesh all of them. This
is what the Ritva says, what he says,
ki mipnei hadochak rashai likboa kodem zmanim. Gemara
in Sanhedrin 12b says you're allowed to be
mekadesh a Chodesh before the Chodesh comes, v'gam
shelo al pi re'iya. And the Gemara in
Sanhedrin says you can also do it shelo
al pi re'iya. So
he took advantage of both those leniencies and
to save the institution of our calendar, and
the Ritva continues in the dot-dot-dot that I
cut out, he says, and if not for
him, who knows what would be with Klal
Yisrael. So we all owe him a great
deal of gratitude, says the Ritva, for doing
that. Okay, so coming back to our shiur.
Let's finish up source number two. So now
that we know based on Hillel HaZaken calculations
and established calendar, asks the Gemara in the
third line: Hashta d'is lan b'keviya d'yarcha mai
ta'ama avdinan trei yomei. If the whole reason
for the two days of Yom Tov, Yom
Tov Sheni shel Galuyos, is that people didn't
know when Rosh Chodesh was, and therefore if
they didn't get the message in time, they
didn't know when Yom Tov should be, so
they had to be on the safe, they
had to practice two days Yom Tov out
of safek. So if we don't have a
safek anymore, we have a set calendar, why
do we have Yom Tov Sheni? Answers the
Gemara, this is the line that we're going
to talk about tonight: mishum d'shalchu misam, they
sent a message from Eretz Yisrael: hizaharu b'minhag
avoseichem biyadeichem. You guys in chutz la'aretz better
be careful with your minhag of your cities.
Why? Why do you have to carry on
your minhag? zimnin d'gazri shmada v'asi l'kilkulei. Because
maybe you're going to be in galus, maybe
in galus there'll be a shmad, and presumably
that means you will forget the calculation, you'll
forget the calendar that Hillel HaZaken established, and
if you'll forget it, you're going to be
in trouble, you're not going to know when
Yom Tovim are. Just look at this line
I underlined. What is he saying in this
line? Are there two things or one thing
here in this line that I underlined: hizaharu
b'minhag avoseichem biyadeichem zimnin d'gazri shmada v'asi l'kilkulei.
It sounds like there's one point. The one
point is you better continue what your minhag
is. Why do you have to continue your
minhag? Because there's a concern that you might
forget about the real way to figure out
Yom Tovim, and therefore just keep on keeping
two days just to protect yourselves. Okay, that's
the Gemara. What I'd like to do now,
we're going to do, it's going to be
a little bit of a different kind of
shiur tonight. I really just want to do
two sources. We're going to have a Rambam,
a bunch of halachos from the Rambam, and
a Ritva. And that limud of the Rambam
and the Ritva will yield two very different
applications of what to do with the city
of Eilat. We're going to come with very
different conclusions. The Rambam gives us a very
clear picture. This Rambam is very ma'arich, and
he's very clear about giving you the whole
history and the whole procedure how we should
figure out how many days Yom Tov should
be in each city. Based on different locations.
And let's see, join me, source number three.
We're going to go through a whole bunch
of Rambams and point out things as we
go through the Rambams and we'll see what
Shittat Rambam will be. And after that we'll
look at the Ritva in depth and we'll
see what the Shittat HaRitva will be. And
then you'll see that they're too they're they're
totally they're totally different one from another. Kach
sach Rambam behilchos kiddush hachodesh perek hey. K'shehaysa
Sanhedrin kayemes vekov'in al har'iyah. When we had
a Sanhedrin, hayu bnei Eretz Yisrael vechol hamakomos
shemagi'in aleihem shluchei Tishrei. You're going to see
that when we talk about messengers that are
sent from Yerushalayim, the Rambam going to say
anyone who could be reached within ten days
was a city that would keep one day
of Yom Tov. Anybody that would be reached
in more than ten days would have to
keep two days of Yom Tov. Where did
these ten days come from? Ten days is
the amount of travel days that you have
during Tishrei because you can't travel to alert
the rest of the golah, the rest of
Klal Yisrael that it's Rosh Chodesh on one
day of Rosh Hashanah, on a Shabbos, on
a day of two days Rosh Hashanah maybe,
two days Rosh Hashanah, a Shabbos, and Yom
Kippur. So how many days do you have
to travel before Pesach, before Succos? You have
ten days because the 15th is already Succos,
so you have 14 days before that. Four
of them were used up for holidays there,
for Shabbos Yom Tov that you're not allowed
to travel. So there were ten travel days.
So therefore, whenever you had ten travel, as
far as you could get for ten travel
days, that was the area that would be
reached, that would know when to make Succos.
That's what he says here. So that distance
really doesn't necessarily tie into whether it's a
part of Eretz Yisrael or not? That's what
we're going to discuss. You'll see what the
Rambam going to say about that. That's that's
exactly where we're going. That will be part
of, that will be a small part of
where we're going. K'shehaysa Sanhedrin kayemes vekov'in al
har'iyah hayu bnei Eretz Yisrael vechol makom shemagi'in
aleihem shluchei Tishrei. That's why he says the
word shluchei Tishrei not shluchei Nissan, because Nissan
you have we only have whatever is in
ten days. Osin Yom Tov yom echad bilvad,
only one day of Yom Tov. However, shear
hamakomos harachokos she'ein shluchei Tishrei magi'in aleihem but
the further locations like in Persia, the Jews
in Iran, right, the Jews in Iran are
there since how long, how long have they
been there? The Iranians, the Persian Jews have
been there since Bayis Rishon, since galus Bayis
Rishon. They've been there for, you know, they've
been there for 800 years before, before Hillel
sat down to figure out what to do.
So they were mamash getting there the entirety,
the entire 800 years of, I'm sorry, the
400 years of Bayis Sheni and another 200
years, another 300 years after Bayis Sheni. Those
700 years they were getting messengers from Eretz
Yisrael when Rosh Chodesh should be. And Iran,
I mean everyone knows the map now because
it's in the news all day long for
the past week. You have Israel, then you
have Syria, then you have Iraq, and then
you get to Iran. And then where the
Jews lived was a little bit, Iran is
gigantic. So you have to pass through all
of Syria, whatever, part of Eretz Yisrael, all
of Syria, all of Iraq which is much
bigger than Syria, and a good part of
Iran which is much bigger than Syria and
Iraq. So that's more than ten days. So
the Persians weren't getting, all those Jews from
Tehran and all those Jews from Mashhad and
Isfahan, Hamadan where Mordechai ve'Esther are buried. They
didn't get their messengers till could be weeks
later. So they would have to keep two
days because even though the shluchin were not
sent over there? The shluchin were sent out
every month. But the amount of... on Pesach
because of... Rosh Chodesh you could travel, you
had no Yom Kippur. Nevertheless the cutoff was
ten days, correct. Okay, so the people that
were like in Iran for example, in Bavel,
would make two days misafek because they didn't
know when Rosh Chodesh was. Let's look at
Halacha Hey. Bizman hazeh she'ein sham Sanhedrin. We
don't have Sanhedrin nowadays. So we would think
that everybody should just follow the calendar. Haya
min hadin sheyihyu bechol hamakomos osin yom tov
echad. Aval. The next word is very important.
Right, somebody asked me this week, somebody sent
me a text message this week, he's a
rebbe, a very chashuver rebbe of chashuve talmidim,
and he said I got a question from
a talmid, could you please send me in
text form in just a few lines why
do we keep Yom Tov Sheini? Everybody says
it's minhag, right? Minhag avoseichem beyadeichem. Minhag avoseichem
beyadeichem. Minhag avoseichem beyadeichem. Sounds like it's a
din minhag, right? What is the lashon of
the next word of the Rambam which I
underlined for you? takonas chachamim hee sheyizharu beminhag
avoseichem beyadeichem. Do you realize the gymnastics the
Rambam just did? He just did a backwards
flip. He took the gemara that says minhag
avoseichem beyadeichem, he says that it's a takana
to follow your minhag. Isn't that funny? It's
a takana to follow your minhag. That changes
things a little bit. That makes that ups
the ante a little bit, it's not just
a minhag, it's a takana that you have
to follow the minhag. Okay, lefikach says the
Rambam in halacha vav: kol makom shelo hayu
shluchei tishrei magiin lo, any place that in
the ten-day trip couldn't be reached by the
shluchim, let's say let's talk about, you know,
the Iranian the people in Tehran, yaasu shenei
yamim afilu bazman hazeh. Certainly America. kemo
shehayu osim bazman shebenei eretz yisrael kovein al
hareiah just like they used to do when
they had the Beis Hamikdash, they should do
now because of this takana. However, uvenei eretz
yisrael bazman hazeh osim yom echad, and the
Israelis, you see what lashon he uses? Says
that he's talking about Eretz Yisrael. Anybody in
Eretz Yisrael bazman hazeh osim yom echad will
do one day, kemin hagam shemeolam lo asu
shenei yamim because Israelis only kept one day,
so they'll continue to keep one day. Fine.
Let's look at halacha tes. Now he's going
to introduce something new. Until now we've been
talking about how far are you from Yerushalayim?
Are you a ten-days distance or more? Now
he's going to introduce something new. ein asiyas
yom tov echad that this idea of doing
one Yom Tov or two days Yom Tov,
teluya bikravas hamakom on closeness on geometric on
on geographical proximity, the ten-day distance.
Okay, so how so? I thought we've been
saying whatever's within ten-days radius keeps one day
and anything past the ten-days radius has to
keep two days. I'll tell you. im yiheyeh
makom beino uvein yerushalayim mahalach chamishah yamim, let's
say there's a place five days away, ufachos
shebevadai efshar sheyagiu lahem hashlichim, a place that's
five days, you and I would say five
days away is definitely going to keep one
day, right? Because they are reached by the
shluchim. Uh-uh. ein omrim sheanshei makom zeh osim
yom tov echad. We're not necessarily going to
say they should keep one day because look
at this new wrinkle that the Rambam introduces.
I underlined it for you. shema lo hayu
hashlichim yotzin lemakom zeh. Maybe the shluchim didn't
go to that city. Why not? mipnei shelo
hayu sham yisrael because there were no Jews
there. veachar shechazru likboa al hacheshbon, maybe
only later yashvu sham yisraelim shechayavim laasos shenei
yamim. And if you know that there were,
if that's Alexandria, if that's clear, if you
know it's within ten days and there were
Jews there, then it's only keep one day.
So when the Rambam was in Egypt, he
kept only one day. Correct. Correct. 100%
correct. And he'll say that soon, I believe.
He'll say that soon explicitly. If Alexandria is
indeed 10-day walk from Yerushalayim. We'll see. Okay,
but he's going to talk about it more
explicitly. What he just said is something incredible.
He just said that the 10- the 10-day
travel is not that you have to be
10 days away in order to keep only
one day of Yom Tov, it's the fact
that the shluchim actually came to your city.
Which means two things: A, that they have
to be able to get there within 10
days, and B, that there were Jews there,
there was a Jewish population at the time
of the Beis Hamikdash. So let's pause for
a second. Let's say you have a city
like Tel Aviv. No, it's not talking about
Tel Aviv yet. We'll talk about that in
like a minute. Some city in Syria, Sidon,
in Lebanon. And let's say there were no
Jews there. What? I want to say that
there were no Jews. No Jews but still
within a 10-day walk. What? Petra. Petra, great,
Petra, fine. Petra's a gambling place, nobody they
gamble in Petra, right? There's gambling in Jordan,
people all the Israelis go to Jordan to
gamble now, right? There's Petra, a casino, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Okay, so it's not a place
for Jewish boys, right? Just like Las Vegas
isn't, even though there's a burgeoning Jewish community
in Las Vegas. So Petra. Petra is within
10-day walk from Yerushalayim, let's assume. But it's
there are no Jews there. So according to
the Rambam, how many days would you have
to keep in Petra? Well, shluchim didn't come,
so you keep two days. So the point
is not the distance. The point is that
shluchim got there. In order for In order
shluchim to get there, it has to be
within the distance, but it also has to
be a Jewish community. Ah, I wrote here
Brisk. I heard on a tape, who was
I listening to? A lot of times what
I do when I'm preparing a shiur for
Thursday night and I work through the sugya
myself, during the course of the week while
I'm driving, I try to listen to shiurim
on the topic also to sort of hear
what other people said. I heard, I think
from Rabbi Rakafet has a tape on this,
he comes here every July to speak every
summer. He quoted, he worked through the sugya
b'iyun and he quotes a minhag from the
Brisker Rav. The Brisker Rav was machmir in
Geula. How far is Geula from the Beit
HaMikdash? Pretty far? 15 minutes? 15 minutes walk?
Geula. Geula, you know like Meah Shearim and
Geula. It's about a 14-minute walk, an 18-minute
walk. He was makpid to not do melacha
on Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot. He was
makpid for Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot in
Geula. Why? Because of this Rambam we just
read. He said how do we know that
Jews lived right over here in Geula? We
know they lived in the Old City. Good.
Maybe they lived in some other place in
Jerusalem? How do you know that they lived
in Geula? How do you know they lived
in Meah Shearim? Meah Shearim is just like
far away. It's just like Lawrence. It's just
like Moscow. How do you know Jews lived
there? Is that wild? Is that a wild
chumra? Who said the Rambam is talking about
in Eretz Yisrael? The Rambam specifically is not
talking about in Eretz Yisrael. We'll get to
it. Okay, fine, so he'll say it explicitly.
He'll say it explicitly about Eretz Yisrael. aval
b'Eretz Yisrael bizman hazeh osim yom echad afilu
bimkomot she'asu shenayim. But maybe,
no, no, that's not clear because that could
be the part of Eretz Yisrael where Jews
lived. So that's not clear. The communities that
did not exist in the time of Beit
HaMikdash? Even though they're two minutes away from
or ten minutes away from? That is correct.
That seems to be shitat HaRambam. That seems
to be shitat HaRambam. The point that the
Brisker Rav was mechadesh that I think Rav
Shlomo Zalman and I think everybody else would
assume not like that is: you think the
Beit HaMikdash was there and in Geula area
you don't think Jews lived there? It's like,
it's like Wall Street is, whatever, I mean
I don't have to think of examples. The
Beit HaMikdash is there, operational, functional, Jews are
in control of Eretz Yisrael, and 15 minutes
away you don't think real estate is, you
know, is, you know? You go to Jackson
or. Right, in Lakewood, they're already out, they're
already in Jackson township. Fine, those who have
Lakewood connections understand that. Continues the Rambam. This
relates to your question about the Rambam living
in Alexandria. v'ilu haya hadavar talui b'kiruv hamakom,
if it was just a matter of geographic
proximity, hayu kol bnei Mitzrayim osim yom echad,
all of Egypt would do one day. Why?
sheharei efshar sheyagio lahem shluchei Tishrei, because all
of Egypt is accessible within ten days. shebein
Yerushalayim u'Mitzrayim derech Ashkelon. If you travel through
the Ashkelon route from Jerusalem, which actually works,
by the way, if you know Ashkelon is
on the border a little bit south, south,
so you just go straight down to Ashkelon,
down to Gaza. That's the fastest way to
get to Mitzrayim pretty much, it's almost the
fastest way. ela mahalach shmona yamim o pachos,
it's eight days max to get to Egypt.
So therefore why in Egypt would we only
do, why if we sit in Egypt do
we do two days? Maybe they keep two
days? Why? Not because it's too far away,
but because maybe in the time of the
Beit HaMikdash there were no Jews in Alexandria.
But there were. In the time of Beit
HaMikdash? Yeah. Okay, so maybe he did keep
one day. Now he's coming to that. That
was in the time of the Gemara. Was
it the time of the Beit HaMikdash? Yeah,
Bayit Sheni is brought down. Yeah, Bayit Sheni.
Okay, fine. Right. The flag that they waved
was a Mishna or a Gemara? It's a
Braisa. It's in Gemara. Okay, great. ushnayim. And
then he says: v'chen rov Surya, the majority
of Syria. Also, again, Syria is not so
big and Syria is right adjacent, you know,
it's also within a ten-day. So again, if
people didn't live there, so you're not going
to be able to have one-day Yom Tov.
Nimtza. Fine. Let's go now to, I broke
this Rambam into pieces. Let's go to source
number five in this Rambam, which is the
middle of Halacha Yud Alef. v'chol makom shebeino
uvein Yerushalayim, any place between there and Yerushalayim,
mahalach asara yamim beshava o pachos, ten days
or less, she'efshar shehashluchim yagio elav, where it's
possible if that's the distance, so people might
be able, the shaliach might be
able to arrive there, ro'im. Now this is
where the words get a little bit difficult.
*Im oto makom me'eretz yisrael shehayu bo yisrael
besha'at hayerushah bekibush sheini* if it's in Israel
and there were Jewish people living there, *kegon*
he gives some cities like Lod *Lod*, *Yavne*,
*Tveria*, then osim yom echad *osim yom echad*.
If it's within ten days and, sorry, if
it's within ten days and Jews are living
there, then it's one day. *Veim oto makom
miSuria* *kegon Tzor* *veDamesek* *Ashkelon*... what? *Ashkelon*'s
in *Suria*? Didn't he just say three halachos,
*halachos* ago *Ashkelon*'s on the way to *Mitzrayim*?
Maybe there were two *Ashkelon*s, that's what some
of the *acharonim* say, yeah. Chutz LaAretz *O
michutz la'aretz o betoch chutz la'aretz* *osim keminhag
avoseihem beyadeihem* *im yom echad yom echad* *im
shenei yamim shenei yamim*. You know what the
Rambam *Rambam* just said? That there are going
to be parts of Chutz LaAretz. *chutz la'aretz*
that will, some places will keep one day,
some places will keep two days. That would
be very strange. That, that we're going to
get in a minute. Yeah, he's going to
say it explicitly in the next line. So
I pointed out in the English that there
are going to be cities in *Suria*, Damascus,
I assume where Jews were living in Damascus,
should keep B'zman hazeh. *bazman hazeh* one day
of *Pesach*, one day of *yom tov*.
We have to ask, we have to go
to Ocean Parkway and Avenue S and ask
the Syrians there because their grandparents came from
Damascus I'm assuming, and ask them if they
kept one day or two days *yom tov*,
you know just the, you know forty years
ago before they moved onto Ocean Parkway. Let's
see number six, *Halacha yud-bet* in the *Rambam*.
What about a place Yerushalayim *shebeino uvein Yerushalayim
asara yamim o pachos me'asara* less than ten
days, chutz la'aretz, minhag? *vehu Suria o chutz
la'aretz ve'ein lahem minhag* if it's a place
that doesn't have a minhag. *minhag*, so it's
not going to be able to follow minhag.
*minhag*. Oh, and this is the punchline, think
Eilat *Eilat* right now, think Eilat *Eilat*. Eretz
Yisrael? *O shehi ir shenitchadsha bemidbar eretz yisrael*
a new city in the desert of Eretz
Yisrael *Eretz Yisrael* aka Eilat. *Eilat*, *o makom
sheshachnu bo yisrael ata* or a place that
Jews just began settling more recently, rov. *osim
shenei yamim keminhag rov ha'olam*. In Eretz Yisrael
*Eretz Yisrael*? *Ma'aleh Adumim* maybe, yeah, yeah, yeah,
*Ma'aleh Adumim* is probably had a settlement. They
didn't have a settlement there? No. Yeah, they
didn't have a settlement. It's a good strategic
location, it's not a mountaintop. Okay. *Osim shenei*...
ah, that's correct. *Hasair hamishtaleach* was over
there right at *eretz gezeira* you're saying. Right.
Ah, interesting, yeah. You there, we did ATVs
in there. We went, when I went with
our group, our summer program, we went ATVing
in the desert and they actually identified right
outside of *Ma'aleh Adumim* and they identified what
they believe, it was probably based on the
measurements from Yerushalayim *Yerushalayim* in the right direction,
a configuration that would make sense, what they
assume would be the *Azazel* hill, *Azazel* cliff.
It was either that or they just wanted
to get money from Americans to go on
their ATV expedition, one of the two. So
what do you see from here? You see
that according to the *shitas HaRambam*, it sounds
certainly from this very last *halacha*, a new
city in the desert. Even if it is
Eretz Yisrael *Eretz Yisrael*. We said before it's
probably not Eretz Yisrael. *Eretz Yisrael*. But even
if it would be in Eretz Yisrael *Eretz
Yisrael*, if you have a new city in
the desert that Jews never lived there, so
that means the shluchim *shluchim* in the time
of the Beis HaMikdash? *Beis HaMikdash* didn't go
there not because they couldn't get there, but
because there was no reason to go there
in the time of the *Beis HaMikdash*, they
would follow, they would not have this one
day leniency, they would keep two days. The
shluchim *shluchim* never got there. According to *shitas
HaRambam* it seems to be eminently clear that
Eilat. *Eilat* should be according to *shitas HaRambam*
two days of
Yom Tov Sheni Shel Galuyot. *yom tov sheni
shel galuyos*. needs Yom Tov Sheni Shel Galuyot?
That's where things are right now. Now, we
finished the Rambam. Wait, there's one day that
Jews did live in a place there. Would
that work? Don't know, don't know, probably not.
Okay, let's see source number seven. Source number
seven is the Ritva. The Ritva is going
to ask a very simple question and we'll
see his answer and we're going to come
out with something very different than the Rambam.
Says the Ritva on Rosh Hashanah daf yud
ches amud alef, ve-yesh od she'eilah gedolah. What
bothers me about the Ritva is the Ritva
assumes something that we who know what the
map of Israel looks like might be bothered
by. Chazal say that how big is Eretz
Yisrael 400 parsaos. 400 parsaos times 400 parsaos.
A parsa is how much is that? 400
parsaos is 400 parsaos. He says it's mahalach
esrim yom le-adam beinoni
she-zeh asarah parsaos. Either way, it's
a very large area. First of all, it's
a square area and Eretz Yisrael as we
know it today is not square, unless the
shape was different then. Secondly, meaning it includes
more areas, but we know, I mean the
Torah says that the Jordan River is the
easternmost border, so you can't get... it's between
the Mediterranean and the Jordan, there ain't no
400 parsaos there. So he's going to be
using this as a calculation, and we know
the numbers don't work for the map that
we know, so it's going to be a
little bit difficult, but you'll see the lomdus,
and the lomdus will perhaps still apply. Asks
the Ritva something very simple. He says it's
impossible that all of Eretz Yisrael could be
reached within 10 days. Funny, because the Rambam
said the opposite, right? Actually true because we
go ahead and... you're right, because the Rambam
said explicitly not that way. Oh you're right,
yes, the Ritva brings that proof. He says
15 days for people to go back home.
Yep. 15 days for the... Motzaei Sukkos 15
days after the... could be, yes, yes, yes,
15 days to go back home, right. 15
days after the regel, you want to give
people up to 15 days to go back
home, right. So that's even more of a
kashya, because it could be a person could
do it in 10 days but he's with
his kids like the scenic... like when you're
driving away from vacation you stop at the
scenic overlook. Bathroom every... I hear. Okay, I'm
not getting into that. Asks the Ritva a
she'eilah gedolah. He says why are you... wherever
the shluchim got, that's as far as you
would only have to keep one day, because
the shluchim. informed the people exactly when Rosh
Chodesh was. The problem was, even Eretz Yisrael
they were not able... they should not have
been able to reach all of Eretz Yisrael
Because if Eretz Yisrael is 400 parsa by
400 parsa, that means let's say Yerushalayim is
smack in the middle, let's say. Let's imagine
is smack in the middle. That means there's
a 200 parsa radius. How long does it
take to walk 200 parsaos? Says the Ritva,
I'm sorry, 400 parsaos, so there's a 200...
right, 200 parsa radius and she-mahalach esrim yom
le-adam, which would be a 20-day walk. A
person, normal person walks Chazal say 10 parsaos
a day, so 200 parsa radius would be
a 20-day walk. And that means to go
from to the edges, to the corners of
Eretz Yisrael should take 20 days. That means
there should be a good half of Eretz
Yisrael that's not reached. Why did they walk?
Why didn't they go by fast horse? I
mean, they walk. Pony Express back then. You
sent shluchim on foot. So that's a good
question. I hear that. Two things. First of
all, horses also have to sleep, as do
shluchim Second of all, a horse doesn't race
continually for a 10-hour day. Meaning horses know
how to run and they could run races,
but they don't run like that continually. Right.
So asks the Ritva, asks the Ritva, you
and I know that Eretz Yisrael keeps one
day, and chutz la'aretz. keeps two days. But
according to my calculations, it seems that there
are many parts of Eretz Yisrael that shluchim
did not arrive at by the end of
10 days. And therefore why do those further
parts of Eretz Yisrael not... why do those
further parts of Eretz Yisrael only keep one
day? They are Eretz Yisrael but the shluchim
didn't reach that far, so why do they
only keep one day? Now the Rambam told
us, addressed this point, and he said whoever
said that Eretz Yisrael keeps one day and
chutz la'aretz Wherever shluchim got, and if there
were Jews there, kept one day. I don't
care where you are, Israel, chutz la'aretz it
doesn't matter. It's nothing to do with Eretz
Yisrael... per se, says the Rambam. It has
to do with how far you are and
where there were Jews there. The Ritva says
no, no, no. We know that Eretz Yisroel
versus chutz la'aretz In fact, you know what
the poskim quote? Yom Tov Sheini Shel Galuyos.
There, the lashon Chazal itself tells you there's
a difference between diaspora versus Israel. The Ritva,
I think, makes that point. So why does
chutz la'aretz all keep two days and Eretz
Yisroel only keep one day? So he says
something interesting. I'll ask you one more question.
Do we make a bracha on a minhag.
Yeah, some do. I spoke about this to
Mincha Maariv this week regarding Rosh Chodesh. Ashkenazim
do, Sephardim don't. The Shulchan Aruch says you
don't make a bracha on a minhag The
Ritva was certainly me’chachmei Sefard. He assumes that
you don't make brachot on a minhag. If
that's the case, he's also bothered by how
in the world do you make brachot on
all of Yom Tov Sheini Shel Galuyos, minhag
avoteichem beyadeichem, right? It's a minhag. I told
you that the Rambam wheedles his way out
of it because the Rambam said it's a
takana to follow the minhag? of your location.
ulai d’Oraita? That doesn't, that's called takana. That's
a takana. But I'm asking about a minhag.
If the reason why we keep two days
in chutz la'aretz is because of minhag avoteichem
beyadeichem, you don't make brachot on a minhag.
How can you make all those brachot on
second day Yom Tov if you're not going
to make a bracha on a minhag. I'm
not familiar with the Ran. Says that at
least if you don't daven, if you don't
make all the brachot, then there'll be a
complete zilzul of Yom Tov. It'll be a
yom chol in the middle of Yom Tov.
I hear. I hear. I guess the Ritva
doesn't hold from that. Why? It's a minhag
Okay, so what does the Ritva say? He
says something. I bolded it. He says when
Hillel ha-Zaken established the calendar, he did two
things. He established the calendar for Eretz Yisroel
and he set a takana that in chutz
la'aretz they should act as though they have
no idea when the Rosh Chodesh is. Let
me say that again. When he made his
takana and he told us when the cheshbon
was for the rest of history, when all
the rashei chodashim is, when the yamim tovim
should be, part of his takana was also
that in chutz la'aretz, you should act as
though you have no idea when the Rosh
Chodesh is. You have no idea when the
calculation is. That's what it means. hitkinu minhag
avoteichem beyadeichem meaning act as though, continue doing
what you've been doing until now, act as
though you don't know how things really are,
act as though there was no kiddush hachodesh.
What he gains by this, and we'll see
how it'll unfold in a minute, it's not
a minhag It's a takana. The takana was
that you should do what... this is the
same thing that the Rambam tried to do
for us a few minutes before. Remember I
told you that the says it's a takana,
the takana is to keep your minhag So
the Ritva is saying a similar thing. He
says there's a takana, the takana is that
those places outside of Eretz Yisroel should act
as though... it's a synthetic minhag of some
kind. The takana is for Eretz Yisroel, one
way and takana is for chutz la'aretz to
ignore this calendar, this clarity that Hillel ha-Zaken
brought to us. That means that that takana
in chutz la'aretz is a real takana and
therefore you can make a bracha on Yom
Tov Sheni. Okay, now with that, look at
what he's going to do now. And this
is the punchline. Source number eight, the last
line, last part of the Ritva. Va'avoteinu hayah
lahem minhagot shonot. There were different minhagim of
how many days to keep, one day or
two days of Yom Tov. veyesh she'osim sheni
yamim veyesh she'osim yom echad. Look at these
four words. Veyesh lanu leilech achar harov. Bechutz
la'aretz ruba hayu osim bet yamim me'olam. In
chutz la'aretz most locations in Chutz La'aretz always
had two days of Yom Tov. So therefore
we're going to follow rov The takana was
that we should follow rov and therefore all
of Chutz La'aretz should keep two days. Why
does the majority of Chutz La'aretz? keep two
days originally? Shelo hayu magiin sham shluchim, lefichach
anu osim kan sheni yamim. That's why we
in Galut keep two days. Bottom line on
page two. Aval berov Eretz Yisrael, the majority
of, vast majority of Eretz Yisroel Israel was
reached by the messengers and therefore ve-osim gam
ken hayom yom echad. Says the Ritba something
incredible. We asked, the Rambam says it depended
on where the shluchim actually got. The Ritba
says I'm going to do something much neater.
I don't care where they actually got or
where they don't get. Since most places outside
of Eretz Yisroel they didn't get that far,
all of Chutz La'aretz. should do two days.
Since most places in Eretz Yisroel they did
get, you should only do one day. But
what do we use as the borders of
Eretz Yisroel, today for this purpose? I mean
sometimes he's also saying two days because at
that time was Chutz La'aretz, but today he's
considered it not like that. That's what we
have to discuss, that's where we're going to
go. What you realize is what Rav Shlomo
Zalman realizes. Let me back up one moment.
According to the Rambam, do I care whether
you're in Israel or in Chutz La'aretz, All
I care is how far away you are
and was there a yishuv at the time
of the Therefore Eilat didn't have a yishuv,
Eilat. is two days. According to this Ritba
we have a whole new world. There's something
called Eretz Yisroel and something else called Chutz
La'aretz Chutz La'aretz I don't care if you
did or didn't have shlichim come to your
town in, let's say Beirut. Beirut is not
far, Alexandria, Alexandria is not far. But you
know what? They're part of an animal called,
a gigantic animal called galus, called Chutz La'aretz
and therefore will follow rov and we'll give
all of those places, including a close place
like Beirut and a close place like Alexandria
in Egypt, will consider them to follow the
and we'll give them a din Chutz La'aretz.
of two days. And Eretz Yisroel. even if
there's some place in Eretz Yisroel that's let's
say very far away, let's say as he
thought in his question that Eretz Yisroel is
so gigantic and there are parts of Eretz
Yisroel you can't reach, if it's part of
Eretz Yisroel most of Eretz Yisroel is reachable
by the and therefore you will have only
one day in Eretz Yisroel So the question
is, how do we define Eretz Yisroel. now?
You wanted it to stay the same as
the original, as the original Eretz Yisroel, boundaries,
whatever the same as what was once. That's
what you're saying and you're entitled to say
that. We'll see that won't help us so
much with Eilat That's why I don't want
Eilat, Okay, we'll get there, we'll get there.
So what we have here is a gigantic
machlokes, by the way, between the Rambam and
the Ritba. The Rambam holds that there are
places in Eretz Yisroel that keep two days,
there are places in Chutz l'Aretz like Beirut
that keep one day. According to the Ritba
it's a clean slice. Which one do we
pasken like? Who do we pasken like? Are
there any places in Eretz Yisroel that keep
two days? Are there any places in Chutz
l'Aretz that keep one day? No. So you'll
tell me what you know, but let's see
what life was like in the time of
the 1400s, 1500s, the time of the Sefer
Kaftor Vaferech. Kaftor Vaferech was a sefer that
wrote about his travels through Eretz Yisrael and
he records minhagim of what he saw, what
he saw as he traveled. ve-im tomar, Sefer
Kaftor Vaferech is talking about different people having
different minhagim, maybe you worry about a certain
thing that's like shtei toros. And he says
don't be worried about people doing different things.
vehincha ro'eh be-Eretz Yisrael, look at the minhagim
that he's recording. He's not telling you he's
telling you historical observations. You know Marco Polo
went traveling and wrote down what he saw?
That's what you have here in the Sefer
Kaftor Vaferech. Lod top line she'oseh yom echad
mi-yom tov. The city of Lod? in Eretz
Yisrael. has one day of yom tov. That
makes sense. Vegass Gat shelo elef vechamesh me'os
amah, it's 1500 amah away. It's a kilometer
away. And guess what? They use two days
of yom tov. Where's Gat? In the middle
of Eretz Yisrael. Isn't this Gat Pleshtim? Lod,
It's Gat next to it's right near the
airport. Right, it's right near the airport. He
says two cities in Eretz Yisrael. one has
a minhag to do one day, one has
a minhag, to do two days, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera. What do you see
from the Sefer Kaftor Vaferech? What was minhag
of Klal Yisrael? You see like the Rambam.
You see like the Rambam that there are
some cities in Eretz Yisrael that do only
that do two days. Nowadays you're right, I
agreed with what you all called out before
that nowadays we only know the difference between
Eretz Yisrael. versus Chutz l'Aretz You see that
wasn't the minhag. of Kaftor Vaferech. The first
person to really raise this issue was Rav
Menachem Mendel Kasher. Rav Menachem Mendel Kasher was
a Gerrer chassid, Gerrer chassid who was an
incredible ohev Eretz Yisrael. He wrote the incredible
encyclopedia Torah Shleimah and he knew kol, he
knew everything ba'al peh, he knew kol HaTorah
kullah ba'al peh. I believe he wanted to
be matir an eruv on Manhattan, not like
Rav Moshe Feinstein. He was an illui atzum,
and he raised... He raised this question before
1948 in a periodical that he was the
editor of called Degel HaTorah. Volume one of
this periodical called Degel HaTorah, look at the
right column. Baruch Hashem or Be'ezrat Hashem Warsaw.
Sheilah L'Gedolei Torah. He's taking this as a
shaila, throwing it out in this periodical to
the Talmidei Chachamim of his generation in this
periodical. He's just sort of fishing for guys,
not guys, my dear esteemed rabanim who are
reading this around the world, let me know
what you think. There's a shaila that's that
might come up soon. Look at this shaila.
Moshavot V'ayarot. This is talking in the 19...
he brought the Gerer Rebbe to Eretz Yisrael.
during the war. So this is probably in
the 20s or 30s when he's still in
Warsaw before he came to Eretz Yisrael. You
mean for a visit? No, he never came.
He never came in 1940. Right. So he
brought the Gerer Rebbe in. He was one
of them, he signed on. Okay. I'm not
saying he did it. I'm saying he was
one of the people who... he was asked
by the Gerer Rebbe to establish the Ger...
he was the Rosh Yeshiva of the first
Ger Yeshiva of the Ger Yeshiva in Eretz
Yisrael? And he was involved in bringing the
Gerer Rebbe somehow involved, I don't know, maybe
in a rabbinical sense, not in a lay
sense. I don't know the details. Moshavot V'ayarot
Shenityasdu Me'chadash B'Eretz Yisrael. There are new cities
and villages sprouting up in Eretz Yisrael V'gam
He'atidim B'Karov L'hivased B'Eretz Yisrael. There are going
to be new cities that will Be'ezrat Hashem
be established, L'hityashev L'hityashev, that will be established
B'makom She'ein Sham Yishuv. V'gam Einam B'toch Techum
Shel Eizeh Yishuv. They're not... you know, they'll
be sprouting up in new areas. Eich Din
Anshei Otan HaMoshavot B'Yom Tov Sheni? What should
be the din for those places? Look on
the bottom, just jump down to the bottom.
V'hineni Bazeh L'va'er L'va'er K'fi Aniyut Da'ati Et
Tochen HaSheilah. I'm going... he then goes on
for four pages to say what he thinks.
U'mevakesh Ani Me'et... I'll tell you, it's on
the top of the next page. I thereby
request from all the Gedolim and all the
Rabanim around the world, please write to me
to tell me what you think. He's throwing
out a shaila. It's a beautiful, beautiful thing.
And then he says... goes for four pages
of what he thinks. One of the things
that he points out is this machlokes Rambam
v'Ritva. I want to finish with Eich Rav
Shlomo Zalman... there are lots of poskim deal
with this shaila. There's a Tzitz Eliezer, there's
a talk about Mah Rav Elyashiv holds. We're
going to go through Rav Elyashiv what Rav
Shlomo Zalman with one mahalach. But to start
his teshuva, he really sets himself up for
success with the first unrelated comment. And
that is, whenever you have to make a
decision, you have to know what kind of
decision you're going to make. When you go
to law, any lawyers here? We have a
lawyer. So when I went to... when I
went to jury duty, one of the questions
that the lawyer asked to see if I'd
be a good juror for their case is,
do I have a problem with the idea
of beyond a reasonable doubt? Meaning, you
don't have to prove something in an American
court. It doesn't have to be true that
he murdered or that he stole. It just
has to be true beyond reasonable doubt that
he murdered or that he stole. Am I...
help me? Yeah, it's a criminal standard for
criminal. Criminal law. Fine. I know you don't
do criminal but you've heard of it. Fine.
Okay. So you don't have to prove anything,
it just has to be something that's beyond
reasonable doubt. Meaning, when you're in a court
of law in America, the parameters are you
have to be able to prove something beyond
reasonable doubt. Okay. Now we have a rabosai,
we have a shaila. I have to figure
out if is supposed to have one day
or two days. Do I have to prove
that it has to be one day or
two days? Or is it enough if I
could make an argument, a logical argument, that
it would have to be one day or
two days? We have a rule safek d'rabanan
l'kula. We have our own rules for resolving
a doubt. So Rav Shlomo Zalman going to
take what you just said and he's going...
Rav Shlomo Zalman going to take what you
just said and inject some steroids into that
comment. Okay. Let's see what he says in
source number 11. Nireh Li L'hakdim D'bechol Yom
Tov Safek is a halacha d'rabanan... second day
Yom Tov is clearly only d'rabanan. The Torah
says only first day Yom Tov is d'oraita.
Second day is clearly only d'rabanan. Maybe it's
even less than a d'rabanan, maybe it's only
a minhag. like the lashon of the Gemara
is minhag avoteinu b'yadeinu. We saw the Ritva
and the Rambam said it's a minhag. that
they... it's a takanah that you have to
follow the minhag. Right. That was the brilliance
the Rambam and the Ritva make to do
that, you know, heebie-jeebie. But let's... look at
this first introductory comment of the Rav Shlomo
Zalman in source number 11. Nireh Li L'hakdim
D'bechol Safek D'minhaga, he's calling it a minhag,
It's a safek not only in d'oraita, not
only in d'rabanan, but it's a safek in
a minhag, So what should you do? You
should follow the din d'oraita, follow the base
din. Don't... to that minhag. Hachonami l'inyan safek
yom tov sheini, which is only then he
introduced the word that the Rishonim use, is
only a takana to follow the fine. So
therefore, if it's a safek if you have
to do the don't you don't have to
do the It's a safek on a d'rabonon.
And then he adds, look at what I
underlined. Meaning, don't do the Yom Tov Sheini,
Don't just do what the din Torah is.
Din Torah is m'deoraisa have one day of
Yom Tov. And now look what he says,
especially here by Yom Tov Sheini? because in
Yom Tov Sheini, who what's being frum? You
want to be real frum? What's being frum?
Keeping Yom Tov Sheini Day in half? I'll
put on tefillin. Day in half? Go ahead
do both. Let's look. B'frat d'lo shayach klal
l'hachmir b'zeh misafek, you can't be machmir misafek.
Sometimes you want to be frum, you'll just
be machmir. Frum here, being machmir here is
not frum, it's perhaps the opposite. Why? Keivan
shek'neged zeh, the opposite, the frumkeit of keeping
Yom Tov Sheni. yesh chashash shel kama tefillos
u'brachos l'vatala. You're going to make a Shehecheyanu
on the second night of the second Seder?
You're going to say asher kidishanu b'mitzvosav v'tzivanu
al achilas matzah, al achilas maror? You're going
to make all those brachos l'vatala, all the
tefillos, all the shmoneh esrei that you're going
to daven on the Yom Tov? that are
a weekday at the end of Yom Tov
You're going to make it as Yom Tov
davening? They're all brachos l'vatala. v'gam bitul mitzvas
tefillin deoraisa, day in half won't help you
with the tefillos, the brachos, with the tefillos,
the shmoneh esrei won't help you. So therefore,
what do we have to, what's the goal,
says Rav Shlomo Zalman? I don't have to
convince you that it should be one day
or two days. All I have to do
is show you that it's a safek. Once
I show you that it's a safek whether
or not you should keep one or two
days, what's going to be the default position?
You're just going to keep one day. So
that's all, he's setting himself up for success.
He doesn't have to prove anything. All he
has to do is sow seeds of doubt
and then he wins. All he has to
do is show that there are going to
be sfeikos. That means he could tell, he
could use svaras now that you wouldn't matir
aguna with. He could say svaras that are
not ironclad, but if it's enough to raise
a doubt, he'll be able to be meikel
and say just keep one day, not two
days. And that's exactly what he's going to
do. I want to show you the main
svara that he says because it's late. Look
at source number 14. He suggests that we
don't pasken like the Rambam who says that
it depends on how far you are, some
places in Eretz Yisrael should keep two days,
some places in Chutz l'Aretz should keep one
day. Nobody does that. I know the Kaf
Hachayim said they did, but says Rav Shlomo
Zalman nowadays we all we follow the Ritva,
and Eretz Yisrael, and Eretz Yisrael That's the
Ritva opinion. It depends if you're in Eretz
Yisrael, But what's the definition of Eretz Yisrael,
Look at this rabosai, if you weren't a
tzioni until now, now's the time to become
tzioni. Join Rav Shlomo Zalman and get on
the bandwagon. Source number 14. Miskeivan she... Okay.
Second line of source number 14. D'af al
gav she'kdusha rishona batla, even though we don't
have kdushas Eretz Yisrael from the time of
Yehoshua, hainu rak l'inyan hamitzvos hatluyos ba'aretz, that
just means we don't have kdushas Eretz Yisrael
as far as the mitzvos. Aval b'yachas l'chashivus
Eretz Yisrael u'kdushasa harei zeh chashuv vadai Eretz
Yisrael gamur. You could have, what did he
just say? He just said you could have
Eretz Yisrael, without kdushas Eretz Yisrael. You could
have a place that's special called Eretz Yisrael,
that doesn't have any mitzvos hatluyos ba'aretz. Wow.
That doesn't sound so Jewish, that sounds very
nationalistic though. Yeah, so he's saying there are
different parts, yeah, Ever Hayarden perhaps, they're considered
Eretz Yisrael, there are no mitzvos hatluyos ba'aretz
though, there's no mitzvos. b'zman hazeh efshar
d'kulu k'vnei Eretz Yisrael chashivei.
B'zman hazeh, this is the punchline that we'll
do, Efshar. D'kulu k'vnei Eretz Yisrael chashivei. Everybody
in the present state of Israel is all
considered Eretz Yisrael people, even the people in
Mibli l'hischashev klal regardless im yesh l'osom hamakomos
din Eretz Yisrael, gam b'yachas l'mitzvos hatluyos ba'aretz.
Even if there are no mitzvos hatluyos ba'aretz.
Even if you tell me that has no
shmita, has no trumos, has no ma'asros, which
by the way is a gigantic sugya not
for now. But even if you say there's
no kdusha, there's no mitzvos in nevertheless, look
at the last line of source number 14.
Keivan d'lo mistaber klal sheb'osah hamedina v'tachas oso
shilton yimatzei chelek mibnei hamedina she'einam nigrarim. achar
cheshbon osa hamedinah. How could you have one
governmental authority, one authority that governs one a
whole region, and say that one is called
the land and one is not called the
land? If there's one authority over the land...
Did you hear Mark's question first? What? Planet
method is the large customs for it. Hold
on. Says Rav Shlomo Zalman, it's not mistaber
that you should have one state and one
authority and part of them are called are
called the land and part of them are
not called the land. And therefore says Rav
Shlomo Zalman, again, he doesn't have this doesn't
have to be an ironclad svara which he
points out later. It's enough of a svara
that even if there's no kedushas Eretz Yisrael
in Eilat, but if Eilat is part of...
how should I finish the sentence? The land
of Israel. I don't want to say Eretz
Yisrael. I don't want to say Medinas Yisrael,
whatever it is. It's part of Israel under
one authority, whatever you want to call that
authority. I think between '67 and '82 it
was the same thing, of course. I didn't
hear what you said. If that's if that's
the case, says Rav Shlomo Zalman, then it
should have a din of Eretz Yisrael? even
if it doesn't have kedushas Eretz Yisrael, even
if it doesn't have any mitzvos hateluyos ba'aretz.
And therefore... how about the other area? How
about the... yeah. I skipped... I did cut
and paste... there's a long tshuva, I did
cut and paste a lot. He he did
have five steps to build up to this
which I skipped. Okay, sorry. No no no
no, it's just I mean this is about
it, it's late as it is. Based on
this, what does Rav Shlomo Zalman say? Rav
Shlomo Zalman says that it's
not clear. Look at source number sixteen which
we'll finish: chashvani zeh she'ein zeh kol kach
barur shechayavim sham Yom Tov Sheni. I'm not
so clear that you have to have ve'im
rak safeik hu, and if it's takka only
a safeik, yeish leilech achar din Torah, you
should follow only the din d'Oraisa, velinhog rak
yom echad bilvad. And therefore because of this
safeik that he has some other speikos which
we didn't mention and this fabulous svara, the
fact that if we pasken again, if we
pasken like the Ritva that it depends not
on how far the get but what is
called Eretz Yisrael? well if Eilat is called
Eretz Yisrael even if there's no kedusha, even
if there are no mitzvos, but if Eilat
is called Eretz Yisrael it's going to have
the din of, like the Ritva says, Eretz
Yisrael. versus galus. Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyos.
Eilat is not galus, it's Eretz Yisrael. And
therefore says Rav Shlomo Zalman, concludes Rav Shlomo
Zalman, you only have one day of in
Eilat, not two days. Even if it's not
a good svara, it's enough of a safeik
to be meikel along with the other speikos
which I didn't have in source number fifteen
and sixteen. And there is, by the way,
we could finish with this, a beautiful svara.
You you could go now, this is just
a cute thing. The Meshech Chochma asks an
incredible question. That is a brilliant question. The
Gemara says, why did Moshe Rabbeinu want to
go into vechi leechol mipiryah hu hayah rotzeh?
I'm just going to answer today. What's the
obvious question? Why did... lekayem es hamitzvos. lekayem
es hamitzvos. The Gemara said... the Gemara... there's
more fundamental question. That's the Gemara answer, lekayem
es hamitzvos. There's a much more simpler answer
to that question. Why did Moshe Rabbeinu want
to go to Guess what? Because there's a
mitzvah to live in like the Ramban says.
It must be, says the Meshech Chochma, the
Gemara didn't say that because Moshe Rabbeinu when
he was in Jordan, he was... that must
have apparently have been mekayem the mitzvah of
Yishuv Eretz Yisrael. rabosai, was there trumos umasros
today in Jordan? No, because the Gemara in
the next line says he wants to go
into to do to do trumos umasros. That
means you have the idea in this Meshech
Chochma of Moshe Rabbeinu being in Jordan, on
the on the far side of the Jordan
River, not in There's no mitzvos but there
is a din of He's fulfilling the mitzvah
of Yishuv Eretz Yisrael even there. rabosai, thank
you very much for joining me and b'ezras
Hashem next week will be a new topic.
We should be zocheh to the...